What's creepier than a clown? An
alien spider from another dimension.
Pennywise's origins are no laughing matter.
The inspiration for Pennywise came to Stephen
King while he was crossing a covered bridge.
In Bev Vincent's "Stephen King: A
Complete Exploration of His Work,
Life, and Influences," the iconic
horror writer is quoted as saying,
"I was wearing cowboy boots with rundown heels,
and I was very aware of the sound they made on
the boards; they sounded like a hollow clock."
His mind recalled the fairy tale "Three
Billy Goats Gruff," and the troll dwelling
below a bridge threatening to
gobble up three goat brothers.
He subsequently imagined an evil force that
could shapeshift into anything its prey feared,
giving King the freedom to write about
all the monsters he could think of.
According to Vincent's book, the idea to
make Pennywise a clown struck King while
he walked the streets of Bangor, Maine after
a rainstorm. While passing a sewer, his mind,
once again, went to that troll under
the bridge. King is quoted as saying,
"As I looked at this one sewer as I was going
by, the voice inside speaks up again and says,
'The troll lives there too, only when
he's in the sewers he has a clown suit."'
“You hear voices from the sewer?”
It's common knowledge that most of Stephen
King's books and short stories are connected,
with the author creating an intricate shared
universe for much of his career. In fact,
a television series set in the fictional
town of Castle Rock brought the author's
various characters and stories together
to tell brand new tales for two seasons.
If you're yet to read any King books, you
may not be aware that his stories actually
take place in a multiverse. Importantly,
there is another dark space outside of
that multiverse called the Macroverse. In his
"Dark Tower" cycle of books, this is referred
to as the Todash Darkness and some pretty freaky
things beyond our comprehension live out there.
One of its inhabitants is a gargantuan cosmic
turtle called Maturin who vomited up our universe
like something out of an ancient creation
myth. Maturin isn't all that interested in
what happens to us, which is why another entity
from the Macroverse was able to enter our space,
crash into an area that would become Derry,
Maine, and feed on humanity for centuries.
The second being is what readers of "It"
know as Pennywise, the Eater of Worlds.
Fiction contains a lot of monsters driven
by hunger. Zombies often shamble through
post-apocalyptic worlds looking for living
flesh to consume while vampires stalk the
night thirsting for blood. While all these
monsters have their own creative strengths
and weaknesses, Pennywise stands apart because of
the sheer joy it derives from hunting its prey.
The entity we refer to as Pennywise doesn't just
kill and eat its food, but toys with it first.
For It, eating isn't enough, and the point is to
savor the meal. Like a chef perfectly preparing
a steak by tenderizing and salting it just
enough, Pennywise preps its food by scaring it.
As a result, the scenes in which Pennywise
takes the form of a werewolf, the Creature
from the Black Lagoon, or a sick and rotting
old man, are It's version of "salting the meat."
"I can smell the stink of your fear."
The flesh of a scared person tastes better
than that of someone who doesn't suspect
they're about to be eaten. This is why It
takes on so many forms, in order to exploit
a person's fear and bring out their very best
flavors. Children naturally scare more easily
than adults because they still believe in the
impossible things that adults lose faith in.
For an adult, believing in supernatural
monsters is a psychological defect.
For kids, belief in monsters is a means of
survival. The monster under the bed can't
get you if you know it's there. Unless, of
course, it decides to come looking for you.
“I thought if maybe you couldn’t see my
face, maybe you’d want to be my friend.”
After crashing into our planet from the
Macroverse, It slept deep below the ground
until the early part of the 16th century,
when mankind started inhabiting the land
above his domain. Awakened from a long, deep
slumber, it was hungry and began devouring the
people going about their lives in this new
world born from Maturin. After about a year
of doing so, It was satiated and returned to its
subterranean home to sleep for another 27 years.
This was the beginning of a cycle of horror
that would continue for more than two centuries.
Pennywise's natural feeding routine is
to wake up every 27 years and eat the
residents of Derry before hibernating. During
this time, the small town goes pretty much
unnoticed by the rest of the world, allowing It
to feed without gaining unnecessary attention.
Inhabitants of Derry seem to forget the
entity's terrible deeds shortly after
they occur. This is why the Losers' Club
have no idea Pennywise even exists when
he starts coming after them in 1957.
One resident remembers seeing Pennywise
the night a lumberjack killed a dozen
men at the dawn of the 20th century,
but didn't know It's name and never told anyone
else. It is this kind of traumatic amnesia that
allows Pennywise to continue feeding unchecked,
until some kids decide to finally fight back.
Obviously, there is nothing realistic about
Pennywise, but that doesn't mean that everything
about King's novel is complete fiction. One
of the most horrific scenes in the book,
and brought to life in "It: Chapter Two,"
involves a homophobic hate crime where a gay
man is beaten and thrown off a bridge. He has
asthma and struggles to keep from drowning. To
make things worse, the individual offering him
a helping hand is Pennywise the dancing clown.
The scene was inspired by the actual 1984
murder of Charlie Howard. In "Stephen King:
A Complete Exploration of His Work, Life,
and Influences," Bev Vincent writes,
"The victim (Howard) did not drown after being
thrown off the bridge into the stream — he
suffocated because of his asthma, which
King likens to being frightened to death."
According to Vincent, King researched the
police investigation of Charlie Howard's
murder and created a fictionalized version of
it for the portion of his book set in 1985.
The decision to include the scene in
"It: Chapter Two" was controversial,
with some regarding it as cheap and
disrespectful. However, director Andy
Muschietti and star Jessica Chastain felt
it was important to include the scene,
because Pennywise represents the darkness
in humans that society prefers to ignore.
As Pennywise is an ancient entity from
another universe, It isn't limited to
the same rules as the rest of us. Instead,
the true form of It is unknowable. However,
we do know that the deadlights seem to
be a kind of power source driving It,
and anyone who sees that power
is driven insane. In the book,
Bill's wife sees them and becomes catatonic
until Pennywise is defeated. This energy also
provides It with a vast array of abilities only
glimpsed in the film and television adaptations.
Shapeshifting and mindreading are the obvious
examples. We know that Pennywise can dip into
a person's consciousness, identify what scares
them most, and then become that thing. However,
it's a lot less clear how It has the ability
to control people. For instance, why don't
Derry residents remember when Pennywise kills and
eats their friends and family? And why is it that
when people move away from Derry, their childhoods
become something akin to barely remembered dreams?
"I forgot. How could I forget?"
Pennywise's ability to control people like
puppets, while also manipulating their thoughts,
is truly terrifying. That manipulation runs
even deeper, with It seemingly able to keep
the town of Derry alive and thriving
despite all the murders that happen
every 27 years. By manipulating the town's
reality, It is able to maintain an endless
food supply. The spell over Derry only begins
to break when Pennywise is finally defeated.
Readers of King's novel join the Losers' Club
on a journey from childhood to adulthood,
experiencing the characters' fears and
heartbreaks for hundreds of pages. In the end,
everything comes down to the group standing up
against Pennywise's most terrifying form yet,
which is a giant spider. While some might find
the villain's final form a little disappointing,
this isn't just any spider,
but a giant pregnant spider.
Suddenly, everything we thought we knew
about Pennywise is thrown out the window,
because it appears as though
the being can reproduce.
Although it's assumed that the spider
is Pennywise's true form, that doesn't
necessarily confirm that It is actually pregnant.
This could be another tactic to frighten the
Losers' Club into thinking there are more of
its kind out there, whether there are or not.
The fact that the book makes us ask these
questions proves that King really tapped
into something special with Pennywise's final
form. When the book is finished, we have no
idea what was real and what wasn't. Was the being
actually female, and did any of those eggs hatch?
More importantly, were those eggs even
real? The doubt that we're instilled with
is actually the point. As the product of a
person's fears and anxieties, it's poetic that
readers and viewers are left with the unsettling
notion that It might not actually be gone.
For any reader really interested in
wandering through Stephen King's multiverse,
there's no better place to do so than
in "The Dark Tower" books. The series
is about a gunslinger named Roland Deschain on
a quest to find the Dark Tower at the center
of the multiverse and climb to the top of it.
While doing so, he travels between realities,
encountering characters from other King books
like Father Callahan from "'Salem's Lot,"
Patrick Danville from "Insomnia," and multiple
forms of Randall Flagg from "The Stand."
The way in which Roland meets Patrick Danville
is actually tied to "It." In the final book,
"The Dark Tower," Roland ventures into the land
of Empathica, where he is taken in by someone
calling themselves Joe Collins. This person gets
assistance from an android called Stuttering Bill
and seems like a nice, funny guy until the
truth sets in. As it turns out, this isn't a
former standup comedian called Joe Collins, but
Dandelo, a being that feeds on human emotions.
Dandelo keeps Danville in the basement
where he eats the young man's emotions.
He gets close to killing Roland, too, but the
gunslinger and his companion manage to defeat
the creature. They rescue Danville, and continue
their quest. But the fact that Dandelo feeds on
emotion immediately makes the reader think of
Pennywise. According to author Bev Vincent,
"King has stated that Dandelo is not Pennywise,
but they may be from the same species."
It would seem that having its
heart crushed by Bill Denbrough
would be enough to kill Pennywise for
good. After all, once It is murdered,
the spell over Derry dissolves, and memories
of Pennywise's evil begin to fade. However,
Stephen King has hinted in subsequent books
that Pennywise may not be gone for good.
"Oh yes, they float."
In "The Tommyknockers," a character travels to
Derry and has a vision of a familiar-sounding
clown in a sewer. The character in question isn't
doing well mentally, so he might just be having
a hallucination that just so happens to connect
to one of King's older works. A more substantial
hint, though, comes in "Dreamcatcher," a novel
about adults dealing with their past traumas.
The alien in "Dreamcatcher" is referred to as
Mr. Gray, which is extremely similar to one of
Pennywise's aliases, of Robert or Bob Gray.
The alien visits Derry in order to poison
the water supply but learns that the Derry
Standpipe was destroyed during the events of
"It." On a plaque commemorating those who died
in the 1985 flood, someone has spray-painted the
words "Pennywise Lives." Was this the result of a
lingering memory in the mind of a Derry resident,
or a warning that Pennywise isn't done
with the people of Maine? For now,
that's another question only King
fans can answer for themselves.